[Musique]
victor s'envole bientôt pour l'espagne
mais le jour du départ l'agent de bord
lui refuse l'embarquement raison son
passeport expire moins de trois mois
après la date de son retour
victor apprend que certains pays ont des
exigences d'entrée et de sortie
ceux qui font partie de l'espace
schengen comme l'espagne exigent des
voyageurs qui détiennent un passeport
valide au moins trois mois après la date
prévue de leur sortie et attention
certains pays comme le brésil la
thaïlande et la russie exige que le
passeport soit valide 6 mois après la
date de sortie
si l'agent l'espace et victor et que
l'espagne mais refuse l'entrée
le transporteur sera mis à l'amande et
devra le ramener à ses frais victor est
furieux mais c'était à lui de s'informer
le fin mot de l'histoire
passeport trop près de la fin ne vous
mènera à bien loin